the rate at which rainwater flows into a
drain pipe is modeled by the function R
where R of T is equal to 20 sine of T
squared over 35 cubic feet per hour T is
measured in hours and zero is less than
or equal to T which is less than or
equal to 8 so T is going to go between 0
& 8 the pipe is partially blocked
allowing water to drain out the other
end of the pipe at a rate modeled by D
of T it's equal to negative 0.04 T to
the third power plus 0.47 and 60 cubic
feet per hour for the same interval
right over here there are 30 cubic feet
of water in the pipe at time T equals
zero all right Part A how many cubic
feet of rain water flow into the pipe
during the eight hour time interval zero
is less than or equal to T is less than
or equal to 8 all right so we know the
rate the rate that though that the that
things flow into the rainwater pipe
in fact we could let me draw a little
rainwater pipe here just so we can
visualize what's going on so if this is
if that is the pipe right over there
things are flowing in at a rate of R of
T and things are flowing out at a rate
of D of T and they even tell us that
there's 30 cubic feet of water right in
the beginning but these are the rates of
entry and the rates of exiting so how
much water they're asking how much how
many cubic feet of water flow into so
enter into the pipe during the 8 hour
time interval so if you have your rate
this is the rate at which things are
flowing into it they give it in cubic
feet per hour if you multiply it times
some change in time even an
infinitesimally small change in time so
DT this is the amount that flows in over
that very small change in time and so
what we want to do is we want to sum up
these very small these amounts over very
small changes in time to go from
time is equal to zero all the way to
time is equal to eight so this
expression right over here this is going
to give us how many cubic feet of water
flow into the pipe once again what am I
doing R of T times D of T this is how
much flows how what volume flows in over
a very small interval DT and then we're
to sum it up from T equals zero to T
equals eight that's the power of the
definite integral and so this is going
to be equal to the integral from zero to
eight of twenty sine of T squared over
35 DT and lucky for us we can use
calculators in this section of the AP
exam so let's bring out a graphing
calculator where we can evaluate
definite integrals and so let's see we
want to do definite integral so that I
can click math right over here move down
so this function FN integral this is a
this is a integral of our function or a
function integral right over here
somebody press ENTER and the way that
you do it is you first define the
function then you press put a comma then
you say what variable is the variable
that you're integrating with respect to
and then you put the bounds of
integration so I'm going to write 20
sign of and just because it's easier for
me to input X than T I'm going to use X
but if you just do this a sine of x
squared over 35 DX you're getting at the
same value so you're going to get x
squared divided by 35 divided by 35
close that parenthesis so that is my
function there actually I don't know if
it's going to understand
let me I'm just going to understand let
me put the times second insert times
just to make sure it understands that
okay so that's my function and then let
me throw a comma here make it clear that
I'm integrating with respect to X I
could have put a T here and integrated
with respect to T we'd get the same
value comma my zero but my lower bound
is zero and my upper
is 8 and close the parentheses and then
let the calculator munch on it a little
bit and we get seventy six point five
seven Oh
so this is approximately approximately
seventy six point five seven zero now
let's tackle the next part is the amount
of water in the pipe increasing or
decreasing at time T is equal to three
hours give a reason for your answer well
what would make it increasing well if if
the rate at which things are going in is
larger than the rate of things going out
then R then R the amount of water would
be increasing but if it's the other way
around if we're draining faster at T
equals three then things are being then
things are flowing into the pipe
well then R then the amount of water
would be decreasing let me be clear
so amount so if if R of T greater than
actually write it this way if R of three
T equals three because T is given in our
T is measured in hours if R 3 is greater
than d of three whoops then D D of three
if R three squared in the D three that
means water is flowing in at a higher
rate than leaving so that means that
water and pipe right then then water in
pipe increasing increasing and then if
it's the other way around if D of three
is greater than R of three then water
and pipe decreasing and your draining
faster than your putting into it then
water in pipe decreasing decreasing so
we just have to evaluate these functions
at three so let's see are actually I can
do it right over here
so then we come along the line here so R
of three is equal to well let me get my
I calculator out this is going to be
oops that calculator let me get this
calculator out so and I'm assuming that
things are in that things are in radians
here so I already put my calculator in
Radian mode so it's going to be twenty
times sine of whoops 20 times sine of 3
squared is 9 divided by 35 and it gives
us this is equal to five point
approximately five point zero nine so
this is approximately five point zero
nine and to do three DF 3 is going to be
approximately so the calculator back out
so it is we have negative 0.04 times
times 3 to the third power so times 27
plus plus 0.4 times 9 times 90 squared
plus plus zero point zero
oh no it's just zero zero point nine six
nine six times T times three and this
gives us five point four so this is
equal to so this is equal to five point
four so D of three is greater than R of
three so water increasing sorry water
decreasing we're draining faster than
we're punk we're getting water into it
so water water is decreasing